bundesministerium für umwelt und damit
kommen wir zum nächsten einzelplan da
geht es um den etat des
bundesministeriums für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz von bundesministerin
und steffi lemke 2 2 milliarden euro
stehen ihr zur verfügung das ist weniger
als im jahr 20 21 unter anderem liegt
das aber daran dass sich die
zuständigkeiten zwischen den ministerium
ministerien doch etwas verschoben haben
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium kümmert
sich hier nun auf um klimaschutz so dass
dort einige zuständigkeiten hin
gewandert sind die vorher im
umweltministerium lagen
außerdem hat auch nochmal der
haushaltsausschuss denn etat etwas
gekürzt in der bereinigungssitzung das
ist relativ selten vorgekommen nur beim
bundesministerium für ernährung und
landwirtschaft hat auch das als
ausschuss einen geringeren etat
bewilligt
allerdings sollen natürlich auch in
diesem jahr dann und neue
schutzprogramme aufgestellt werden
details und meinungen dazu wenn wir
jetzt hören erster redner ist uwe feiler
berichterstatter für den einzelplan von
der unions fraktion des bundeshaushalts
2022 insbesondere einzelplan 16 anschaut
im ersten regierungsentwurf bis heute
dann wird man nicht viele neuerungen
finden kaum änderungen finden einige
neue etiketten sind mit dabei wie der
bundes naturschutz von denen es in
anderer form in mehreren titeln bisher
auch schon gab das ist auch ein ausdruck
guter arbeit der vorgängerregierung
meine damen und herren
was ist denn jetzt eigentlich die größte
veränderung oder die größte änderung
in ihrem aufbau bundesministerin das ist
die aufteilung des
titels oder des kapitels klimaschutz auf
mehrere ministerien ich habe den
einzelplan beratung bereits
erwähnt dass es sich hier im klein klein
verlieren viele köche verderben
bekanntlicherweise den 3 und wer
eigentlich chefkoch ist beim thema
klimaschutz seitlich chefkoch in dieser
bundesregierung ist das entschließt sich
mir bisher leider nicht
geld meine damen und herren ist der kitt
der diese regierung diese koalition
zusammenhält aber im gegensatz zu den
unendlichen weiten meiner schönen heimat
brandenburg sind die mittel die wir zur
verfügung haben die hart
erarbeiteten steuergelder der
bürgerinnen und bürger endlich sie
nehmen jetzt vier milliarden euro aus
dem klima- und transformation von für
die vorhaben des bmv 4 milliarden euro
neue schulden keine prioritätensetzung
alles ist wichtig sie bauen damit eine
schöne fassade auf für umwelt natur und
klimaschutz und ich möchte kurz auf den
aktionsplan natürlicher klimaschutz
eingehen sie wollen moore wieder
vergessen sie wollen flussauen
renaturieren sie wollen flächen von
waldacker und wiesen der natur
überlassen sie wollen wildnis fördern
das ganze haben sie in einer
wunderschönen hochglanz broschüre
zusammengestellt aber was bedeutet das
eigentlich in der praxis in der praxis
bedeutet dieses einen erheblichen
flächen den zug der jetzigen nutzung
vielleicht ist das alles kein problem
bei bundes oder landes flächen aber die
flächen kulisse in der bundesrepublik
sieht anders aus und es schafft eine
betroffenheit privater landeigentümer
und landnutzer und wir meine damen und
herren wollen keine enteignung durch die
hintertür
aussagen zu kooperations maßnahmen zu
entschädigungen zu der gebietskulisse
überall derzeit fehlanzeige oder wollen
sie gar das verfahren der flug
reinigungsverfahren
miteinbeziehen flurbereinigungsverfahren
meine damen und herren kosten geld aber
vor allem zeit und ich spreche da aus
gute erfahrung es gibt dass die untere
havelniederung das nicht direkt bei mir
vor der haustür das
flurbereinigungsverfahren was dort
gerade läuft dauert 15 jahre bisher und
die der abschluss ist offen also es
lohnt sich einen blick hinter die
kulissen hinter die fassade
ihrer klimapolitik und ich sehe dort
eine großbaustelle und ob wir innerhalb
der nächsten vier jahre innerhalb dieser
legislatur sichtbare baufortschritte
sehen dass das ist bei mir noch ein
bisschen fraglich also eine
hochglanzbroschüre reicht daher nicht
aus und vielleicht geben sie ja dieses 4
millionen euro schulden oder neu spielen
die dass diese tat machen vielleicht
gehen sie das geld gar nicht aus und es
war in den beratung noch wichtig der
internationalen meeresschutz gegen die
vermüllung der meere dazu haben wir auch
einen entsprechenden antrag gestellt sie
haben die mittel zu den ersten
regierungsentwurf um fast 30 prozent
gekürzt
obwohl der mittelabfluss in den
vergangenen jahren sehr gut war
deutschland kann bei diesem thema eine
vorreiterrolle übernehmen und neue
märkte für unsere unternehmen
erschließen wir wollten daher zurück auf
den ursprünglichen ansatz des ersten
regierungsentwurf es aber leider haben
sie das trotz einer von uns
vorgeschlagenen gegenfinanzierung ab
auch beim national meeresschutz
stichwort munition in der nord und
ostsee
sind sie unserem antrag da nicht gefolgt
sie setzen ja eine millionen euro ein
davon 4000 euro für die munitionsbergung
wir wollten erhöhen von einer million
euro auf fünf millionen euro wir wollten
nicht kleckern wir wollten klotzen
leider haben sie das abgelehnt trotz
lobende worte aus der
regierungskoalition
sie klettern lieber statt zu klotzen und
meine damen und herren einen themen ein
paar sätze noch zum thema wolf sie
setzten 100.000 euro für sogenannte
herren schutz esel ein
lobenswert aber es treibt jeden weite
tierhalter glaube ich die zornesröte ins
gesicht und wenn man sich in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag einmal umschaut dann
findet der mann oder findet man dort
einen sehr guten satz sie wollen damit
das gold monitoring- mit den ländern
verbessern und regionale begrenzung der
population ermöglichen das ist ein gutes
vorhaben übrigen ein vorhaben von
bundesministerin a d julia klöckner und
ihrem parlamentarischen staatssekretär
uwe feiler aus der letzten
legislaturperiode
gescheitert ist das ganze an der spd und
dem bmi ob jetzt gerade die fdp
diejenigen sein werden die dieses
vorhaben voran tragen werden wage ich zu
bezweifeln
für die ländlichen räume und für die
weltweite tierhalter und wäre es gut
machen sie es einfach machen sie es
einfach sie haben uns da wirklich an
ihrer seite ich bin gespannt wie es
weiter geht nach dem haushalt ist
bekannterweise vor dem haushalt der
bundeshaushalt 2023 wirft seine schatten
voraus ich bin nicht band auf themen wie
die schuldengrenze auf
prioritätensetzung ihren haushalts für
das jahr 2022 werden wir leider nicht
zustimmen könnten
vielen dank herr kollege
uwe feiler war dass auch der nächste
redner ist für seine fraktion
berichterstatter für den einzelplan 16
sebastian schäfer für bündnis 90 die
grünen
der präsident sehr geehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen im jahr nach der
bundestagswahl wird der etat erst im
frühjahr beschlossen nach acht jahren
großer koalition hat jetzt die ampel
zügig verantwortung übernommen und wenn
ich dem vorredner so zuhört bis es
wirklich notwendig und dringend gewesen
viele ministerien sind neu zugeschnitten
worden auch das wfv hat mit dem
verbraucherschutz eine neue gestalt
bekommen der haushalt wird nur ein gutes
halbes jahr in kraft seien insofern kann
man durchaus von einem übergangs
haushalt sprechen das heißt aber nicht
dass wir mit diesem haushalt nicht
gestalten es gibt eine ganze reihe
positiver entwicklungen zu verzeichnen
unter anderem den aufwuchs im bundes
naturschutz fonds die ampel setzt damit
ein arten hilfsprogrammen für arten auf
die besonders vom ausbau erneuerbarer
energien getroffen sind so adressieren
wir konflikte zwischen klima und
naturschutz die den ausbau erneuerbarer
energien leider lange blockiert haben
mit dem bundes naturschutz von verbinden
wir außerdem eine reihe von bestehenden
titeln um damit auch eine erhöhte
flexibilität in der bewirtschaftung zu
schaffen es gibt einen deutlichen
aufwuchs beim nationalen meeresschutz
verbesserte mittelausstattung für
maßnahmen zur anpassung an den
klimawandel
wir können die erhitzung nicht mehr
zurückdrehen die folgen erleben wir alle
in unseren wäldern und auf unseren
äckern wie drastisch diese folgen schon
global sind sehen wir ja leider zurzeit
in indien über das parlamentarische
verfahren haben wir außerdem dafür
gesorgt dass das recycling label
zentraler bestandteil einer
funktionierenden kreislaufwirtschaft
zügig eingeführt werden kann hier liegt
eine große chance für unsere
volkswirtschaft die es jetzt zu nutzen
gilt
ganz besonders wichtig waren uns die
mittel für investitionen zum schutz des
klimas und der biodiversität auf
internationaler ebene
hier liegen die mittel nun im bmw kam
aber das umweltressort kann in der mit
bewirtschaftung auf diese mittel zu
greifen wir haben den ansatz dafür im
parlamentarischen verfahren noch einmal
deutlich erhöht während die klimakrise
im öffentlichen bewusstsein angekommen
ist sind uns die auswirkungen des
artensterbens noch immer viel zu wenig
präsent von den geschätzten acht
millionen tier und pflanzenarten ist
eine million vom aussterben bedroht die
biomasse an fluginsekten ist in
deutschland an manchen orten um 80
prozent zurückgegangen das hat große
auswirkungen auf vögel und die
bestäubung von pflanzen die natur um uns
herum stirbt aber wie bei der klimakrise
nehmen wir das problem erst mit großer
verzögerung war
mit dem zusätzlich bereitgestellten
mitteln können wir auch auf der
artenschutzkonferenz in kommingen einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten und zeigen
dass wir unsere internationale
verantwortung als viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt ernst nehmen
der erhalt der biodiversität und der
kampf gegen die klimakrise einen sehr
eng zu und ich bin froh dass wir mit
diesem tag gegen die krise ankämpfen
vielen dank
hinter der kollege
die
berichterstatter zu den einzelplänen
sitzen ja immer in dem
haushaltsausschuss und auch wolfgang
wille ist mitglied des
haushaltsausschusses und mitglied der
afg fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident kolleginnen
und kollegen der schutz unserer
lebensgrundlagen ist heimatschutz und
schon dadurch ein grundanliegen
konservativer politik er gerät zum
leidwesen von millionen menschen immer
mehr in den würgegriff der grundfalschen
energiewende politik auch wenn ihr haus
von ministerin
einige thema ihren kollegen harbeck
abgegeben hat bleiben sie zuständig für
den emissionsschutz und den naturschutz
im sinne zahlloser betroffenen fordere
ich sie an dieser stelle dazu auf bei
den abstandsregeln für wind
industrieanlagen härte zu zeigen
die beratungen im haushaltsausschuss
habe offengelegt dass die koalition
darüber streitet je näher die windräder
an die wohnhäuser rücken desto größere
die belastung durch schall und
schattenwurf das landschaftsbild wird
vielerorts durch die verspargelung
zerstört in einer anderen frage des
immissionsschutzes nämlich bei den
sowieso schon sehr strengen stickoxid
grenzwerte hat ihr haus unerbittliche
härte gezeigt und bei den fahrverboten
mitgewirkt
wenn sie nun gegenüber der windindustrie
wenigstens halb so viel härte zeigen
würden wie damals ihre amtsvorgängerin
gegen die autofahrer wäre der natur und
vielen menschen sehr geholfen
[Applaus]
die projektförderung dem einzelplan 16
haben wir bei den haushaltsberatungen
genau betrachtet und ich danke für die
auskünfte die fdp fraktion wird darüber
wachen dass fördergelder nach klaren
fachlichen kriterien vergeben werden wir
werden das hartnäckig aufzeigen wenn
sogenannte
nichtregierungsorganisationen sich in
gut geförderte regierungs
hilfsorganisationen verwandeln zum
verlängerten arm der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit der regierung
werden und wie in anderen grün geführten
ministerien vielleicht sogar
regierungspersonal stellen
für den umweltschutz die
energiesicherheit und die deutsche
volkswirtschaft und damit auch den
bundeshaushalt wäre der weiterbetrieb
der kernkraftwerke von größter bedeutung
dass sich das umweltministerium hier
weiter quer stellt stößt auf die
energische kritik der alv die fraktion
die betreiber der kraftwerke sind da
wesentlich kooperativer
aber ihre reaktion zeigt auch 1 das
ideologische hin und her der politik
unter den kanzlern schröder merkel und
scholz hat dort alles an vertrauen
zerstört
wenn die regierung neue öl- und
gasheizungen verbietet und der strom für
die wärmepumpen unbezahlbar wird ist für
viele bürger der holzofen die letzte
rettung um nicht zu frieren wie in der
steinzeit
es kann nicht sein dass sich das
umweltbundesamt auch noch anschickt
holzöfen zu verbieten dieses amt ist
kein frei schwebender diskutiert club
sondern eine bundesbehörde unter ihrer
verantwortung von ministerin lemke
weisen sie dass opel an
die bürger viel mehr über das richtige
heizen mit holz aufzuklären
gerade das umweltministerium müsst ihr
bei gedrucktem papier und üppigen reisen
ein vorbild bei der sparsamen
haushaltsführung sein hier müsste
verstärkt mit digitalen medien
gearbeitet werden aber selbst diese
kleine und eigentlich
selbstverständlichen änderungsanträge
der fdp-fraktion wurden abgelegt wir
werden dem einzelplan 16 wegen fehlender
ausgewogenheit nicht zustimmen
vielen dank herr kollege
[Applaus]
nun erhält das wort der kollege michael
tc spd-fraktion
michael thews ist auch berichterstatter
führen diesen einzelplan
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
der geehrte damen und herren kolleginnen
kollegen wir beraten heute über den
haushalt des ministeriums für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz und gerade nach dieser
unterirdischen rede hier auch von der
rechten seite muss man auch klar noch
mal sagen wir beraten über die
notwendigen mittel für die sicherheit
des lebens auf unserer erde für uns und
für nachfolgende generation ich will das
hier noch mal ganz klar sagen wir
müssen das was wir wissen unsere
erkenntnisse unter potenzial für die
zukunft nutzen und wir müssen aufhören
an einzelnen sachen herumzudoktern
sondern es gilt die systeme zu retten
unsere ökosysteme und artenvielfalt
unsere meere moore wälder nachhaltig zu
schützen es geht um nicht weniger als
den schutz unserer natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen
heute kommt dass in diesem einzelklagen
zum ersten mal das schutz der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
enthalten ist und damit eben auch der
schutz der rechte für uns alle hier gibt
es auch schnittmengen zu den klassischen
umweltthemen zum beispiel bei dem
bereich recht auf reparatur oder beim
neuen recycling label um mal zwei
beispiele zu nennen wir beschließen in
diesem jahr unter anderem einen aufwuchs
an mitteln für kommunale projekte zum
natürlichen klimaschutz mehr geld für
den meeresschutz mehr geld für die
kreislaufwirtschaft und den schutz der
meere wir stellen für den natürlichen
klimaschutz für die nächsten jahre
ausgaben in höhe von vier milliarden
euro bereit und damit setzen wir den
koalitionsvertrag aktiv um wir haben
vereinbart ein aktionsprogramm
natürlicher klimaschutz und damit
schaffen wir und fördern wir synergien
zwischen den natur und den klimaschutz
durch den aktualisierungs maßnahmen bei
mir im wahlkreis zu beobachten an der
lippe und den nebenflüssen beseitigen
wir aktiv die fehler der vergangenheit
funktionierende stabile ökosysteme wie
moore wälder owen grünland unsere meere
und küsten wirken eben auch gegen die
klimakrise gesunde ökosysteme und
gleichzeitig die vorwürfe sind
gleichzeitig eine vorsorge gegen die
folgen der klimakrise gesunde böden
speichern wasser welt erhalten stirn
besser stand und verhindern weitere
erosionen intakten halten wasser zurück
und schützen so auch vor hochwasser
folgen im parlamentarischen verfahren
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass wir im
aktionsprogramm natürlicher
klimaschutzmaßnahmen vorgesehen werden
durch die der klimaschutz in kommunalen
gebieten und den ländlichen räumen
besonders vorangebracht werden kann
förderfähige projekte sollen aus den
maßnahmen zur natürlichen klimaschutz
veranschlagt mittel finanziert werden
und hierzu wird es 2023 einen förder
aufruf geben neu im bundeshaushalt ist
der start des recycling lebens und da
denke ich noch mal den kollegen dass sie
unserer initiative dort gefolgt sind und
dass wir jetzt starten können quasi mit
dem recycling label auch schon in diesem
jahr ganz wichtig denn hier wird der
einsatz von rezyklaten gefördert in
neuen produkt das die voraussetzung für
eine nachhaltige kreislaufwirtschaft
dafür setze ich mich auch schon seit
jahren ein ein label das verbindlich
transparent und verlässlich auskunft
gibt über den anteil der 30 grad in
sekundärrohstoffen die ein produkt
enthält und ein derartiges label
erleichtert eben auch unter anderem die
öffentliche beschaffung damit wollen wir
das ganze system auch fördern und es ist
eben auch wichtig im vorarbeit
verbraucherschutz weil auch verbraucher
wollen natürlich nachhaltige produkte
kaufen und hier können sie die da klar
erkennen das spart co2 und schützt die
natürlichen ressourcen
ein wichtiger teil des umweltschutzes
ist auch der nationale meeresschutz hier
werden die nächsten jahren sieben
millionen euro eingestellt ganz wichtig
weil es gilt auch die altlasten aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg in nord und ostsee zu
beseitigen 1,6 millionen tonnen munition
liegen dort noch im wasser sie müssen
umweltfreundlich und sicher entfernt
werden dafür haben wir den staat jetzt
gelegt wir gehen das problem zusammen
mit den ländern an werden in den
nächsten jahr für eine ausreichende
finanzierung sorgen hier ist zu lange zu
wenig passiert
ebenfalls im parlamentarischen verfahren
haben hier im bundes naturschutz und
zusätzliche gelder zur förderung von
wattenmeer zentren erreichen können wir
fordern somit den schutz für das umwelt
und natur bewusst sein dieses
einzigartigen küste dieser einzigartigen
küstenregionen diese woche beschließen
wir den haushalt 2022 kürze werden wir
auch schon über den haushalt 2023 in
erster linie beraten
hier gilt es eben auch weiterhin die
notwendigen mittel bereitzustellen
vielleicht sogar noch an der 100 stelle
einen aufwuchs zu erreichen ich bedanke
mich hier nochmal recht herzlich bei den
berichterstatter kollegen bei den
mitarbeitern und bei der ministerin für
die gute zusammenarbeit aber auch bei
den büros der ag der fraktion und bei
den abgeordneten vielen dank für die
gute zusammenarbeit ich hoffe dass wir
das in nächster zeit fortsetzen
können
nochmal der dank von michael thews das
passiert oft in den haushaltsdebatten
dass sich dort die kolleginnen und
kollegen bedanken wenn man nicht im
plenum vor den kameras ist dann scheint
es doch einen oft einer recht produktive
zusammenarbeit zu sein ralph lenkert
spricht jetzt für die linksfraktion
sie behaupten die umwelt hätte priorität
und dann geben sie nur 0,5 prozent der
haushaltsmittel an das umweltministerium
das ist absurd in summe sind es 2,2
milliarden euro und die hälfte nämlich
1,1 milliarden euro sind allein für die
verwahrung des atommülls notwendig ganze
472 millionen euro stehen dem
umweltministerium für realen
umweltschutz zur verfügung hinzu kommt
jährlich eine milliarde für 16 maßnahmen
komplexe zum natürlichen klimaschutz und
forschungsmitteln bildungstag das ist
auch in der summe viel zu wenig aber
selbst in diesen niedrigen umwelt der
tat würde andere schwerpunkte setzen wir
fordern die einrichtung von total
schutzzonen in nord und ostsee zu
überleben von schweizweit durch und
hering und jährlich 50 millionen euro
als unterstützung für das überleben der
fischereibetriebe von usedom bis am
morgen wir fordern zusätzliche 50
millionen für kommunale
lärmschutzprojekte an straßen und
schienen damit anwohnerinnen und
anwohner gesund bleiben
wir brauchen zusätzlich 1 millionen euro
für den ausbau von naturschutzprojekten
und den rückbau von beeren und das
entfernen von beton aus unseren flüssen
artenschutz darf nicht an der
wasseroberfläche enden
bei der frage ob deutschland bei mir im
thüringer wald im schiefergebirge im
harz fast überall sieht man klaffende
wunden in unseren wäldern die wälder
sind unverzichtbar als co2 senke zum
klimaschutz als holzlieferant für
alternativen die industrie zur erholung
zum schutz vor überschwemmungen nach
starkregen und es wasserspeicher auch
für trinkwasser die fachleute meines
thüringen kost sagen ohne umbau droht
einem viertel unserer wälder das aus von
den 11,4 millionen hektar deutscher wald
sind drei millionen hektar anfälliger
monokultur wald der muss zu
laubmischwäldern umgebaut werden
und 285 1000 hektar wald verloren wird
durch stürme und borkenkäfer allein in
den letzten drei jahren kost betriebe
brauchen dringend hilfe zum waldumbau
zur schadholz beseitigung und
wiederaufforstung das ist unverzichtbar
laut bayerische landesanstalt für wald
und forstwirtschaft
ist waldumbau ähnlich aufwendig wie
neuanpflanzung auf 8000 hektar auf 8000
euro je hektar belaufen sich die kosten
waldumbau und wiederaufforstung
erfordern also mindestens 25 milliarden
euro nur knapp 90 millionen für den bald
fanden wir im haushalt im klima- und
transformations- form stehen 200 für den
waldumbau die sind aber leider gesperrt
gesperrt bis die bundesministerium sich
auf ein gemeinsames bald konzept einigen
unfassbar
koalition und union schaffen kein
gemeinsames konzept zur rettung unserer
wälder aber eine grundgesetzänderung für
aufrüstung die ich kriegen sie denn das
ist eine schande
die linke fordert hätten sie die sperre
der 200 millionen für den waldverkauf
mit den 200 und in 90 millionen jährlich
bräuchte ja bald und baut dann ganz 80
jahre
kolleginnen kollegen so viel zeit haben
wir nicht sie haben im koalitionsvertrag
versprochen den forstbetrieben
ökosystemdienstleistungen zu honorieren
wo finde ich die umsetzung dieses
versprechens
die bürgerinnen und bürger der waldumbau
braucht viel zusätzliches personal
kostet geld und er verrät zukünftige
einnahmen der frost unternehmen aber wir
alle brauchen gesunde mischwälder und
ich wiederhole als co2 senke zum hin zu
schutz als rohstofflieferant zur
erholung und als hochwasserschutz und
deshalb brauchen die forstbetriebe
trinkgeld für den waldumbau für gut
bezahlte weil arbeiterinnen und
waldarbeitern mit jährlich einer
milliarde zusätzlich könnten wir es bis
2045 schaffen unsere wälder umzubauen
meine fraktion wird ihnen dieser woche
viele alternativen zu den 100 milliarden
sondervermögen der bundeswehr benennen
und ich trage
wenn die umwelt wenn der wald wenn
unsere lebensgrundlagen zerstört sind
wofür braucht es dann noch kriegs
fregatten
verzichten sie auf die 59 hochsee
fregatten 126 die fast sechs milliarden
euro kosten mit diesem geld wäre der
waldumbau zumindest bis 2028 erst einmal
abgesichert vielen dank
ralf lemke kritisierte die uneinigkeit
der koalition zum schutz bzw aufforstung
der wälder
auf ihn folgt nun frank schäffler fdp
fraktion und mitglied des
haushaltsausschusses
kollegen der 116
sagt ja schon im namen des ministeriums
um was es geht umwelt natur nukleare
sicherheit und verbraucherschutz ich
will mal mit dem schluss anfangen mit
dem verbraucherschutz als ein thema das
jetzt neu hier angesiedelt ist wir
setzen uns als freie demokraten für den
mündigen verbraucher ein wir wollen die
grundlage dafür schaffen dass der bürger
ein verantwortlich seine konsum und
seine investitionsentscheidung schaffen
es all das was dazu beiträgt dass der
bürger als mündiger bürger selbst
entscheiden kann das werden wir
unterstützen
22 milliarden und fasst der kernhaushalt
des etats aber dazu kommen ja noch die
mittel des egf deshalb ist es zwar ein
kleiner haushalt aber dennoch
wirkungsmächtig in dem was er sonst noch
zu bieten hat im naturschutzbereich
wollen wir die rechte der eigentümer
stärken weil wir glauben dass so nur ja
die kooperations die kooperation der
flächennutzung als zentraler baustein
auch genutzt werden kann und deshalb
halten wir den vertragsnaturschutz für
das recht richtige instrument zur
förderung des naturschutzes
der größte anteil
im
haushalt ist der bereich nukleare
sicherheit eine milliarde umfasst dieser
bereich für die zwischen- und
endlagerung radioaktiver abfälle
im wesentlichen
korrespondiert das mit der finanzierung
über den vor zur finanzierung der
kerntechnischen entsorgungen dem 24
milliarden von der industrie eingezahlt
wurden und die laufenden erträge dazu
dienen eben unter anderem diese eine
milliarde zwischen und endlagerung
radioaktiver abfälle zu finanzieren
ich glaube wir tun gut daran in
deutschland wenn wir die
kerntechnik weiter als
nutzbare energie
erhalten
vielleicht ist es sinnvoll auch nach dem
gestrigen tag als russland angekündigt
hat niederlande das gas abzustellen über
alternativen auch in deutschland
nachzudenken zumindest diese option für
die zukunft offen zu halten das halte
ich für richtig robert habeck hat mit
recht gesagt dass es keine denkverbote
geben darf und ich finde auch bei der
kernenergie darf es keine denkverbote
geben
wichtig ist für uns als fdp
ein thema was vielleicht noch nicht so
richtig im fokus stand da ist der
meeresschutz
ich glaube das was wir in der nord und
ostsee und altlasten haben
muss uns zum handeln auffordern 16
millionen tonnen munition
5000 tonnen chemische kampfstoffe aus
dem zweiten weltkrieg sind nicht nur
eine umweltbelastung die auf uns zukommt
sondern sie verhindert auch technischen
fortschritt sie verhindert dass nutzbar
machen der meere und deshalb ist eine
nicht nur eine ökologische aufgabe
sondern es auch eine ökonomische aufgabe
dass wir in den nächsten jahren hier
handeln das machen wir indem wir
haushaltsmittel hier zum hier
bereitstellen aber das erfordert in den
nächsten jahren einen ganz erheblichen
aufwuchs und das haben wir auch im
koalitionsvertrag schon
niedergeschrieben wir wollen die berge
vernichtung von munitions altlasten in
der nord und ostsee mit einem
sofortprogramm sowie mit einem bund
länder vor für die mittel- und
langfristige bergung einrichten und
solide finanzieren in diesem haushalt
haben wir mit einer millionen mittel
begonnen ist auch ein kurzes
haushaltsjahr ich glaube es ist eher ein
symbolischer wert aber es dient dazu in
den nächsten jahren hier einen
erheblichen aufwand auch zu starten oder
ein thema ist uns auch sehr wichtig das
ist ein anderer stelle vorher schon mal
genannt worden dass das thema wolf ich
glaube wir haben im koalitionsvertrag
mit recht
niedergeschrieben dass wir ein regional
differenziertes bis bestandsmanagement
ermöglichen wollen und dieses
bestandsmanagement das erfordert auch
die
entnahme von fünf beständen in
deutschland das ist ebenfalls notwendig
des stands management setzt voraus dass
man auch hilfe entstehen können muss und
deshalb glaube ich muss das in den
nächsten haushaltsberatungen diesen ist
uns noch nicht gelungen aber in den
nächsten haushaltsberatungen ebenfalls
gegenstand der verhandlung sein vielen
dank
vielen dank herr kollege schaeffler war
zügig frank schäffler war das hier in
der debatte und nächster redner ist
alexander engelhard für die
unionsfraktion
präsident meine daumen haben
dass ich in der alles müller in der
haushaltsdebatte umwelt zum thema wasser
sprechen darf passt sehr gut mein
großvater pflegte zu sagen
kinder ihr wisst nicht was das wasser
dem müller für sorgen bereitet weil zu
wenig wasser stand die mühle bei zu viel
aber auch plus der sorgen die sie aus
den hochwassergebieten kennen
das thema wasser müsste auch der
bundesumweltministerin am herzen liegen
die nationale wasserstrategie ist
zumindest angekündigt auch in
aktionsprogramm natürliche klimaschutz
soll auf dem weg sein viel konkretes
gibt es dazu allerdings noch nicht und
der schwerpunkt wasser ist im
haushaltsplan an entscheidenden stellen
nicht erkennbar
mein eindruck ist und eher verfestigt
sich wenn ich mir den aktuellen haushalt
anschauen dass die bundesregierung
falsche schwerpunkte setzt und nicht
effizient mit steuergeldern umgeht
fast 140 milliarden euro neue schulden
fast acht prozent inflation eine kaum
mehr kontrollierbaren geldmenge und dazu
kommt die korona pandemie der krieg in
der krone die grüne transformation und
weitere große herausforderungen
angesichts dieser immensen aufgaben
sollte die bundesregierung sorgfältiger
mit ihren ressourcen umgehen
das fängt beim personal an ich habe
größte zweifel dass knapp 10.000 neue
stellen in der verwaltung ein
effizienteres regieren ermöglichen
vielmehr bin ich überzeugt dass diese
zusätzliche dass dieses zusätzliche
personal zu einer bürokratischen
mehrbelastung für unsere wirtschaft
führt weitere produktivitätsverluste
sind damit garantiert
ehrlich es
ehrlich gesagt
sollte es mit dir fällt es mir in diesem
zusammenhang schwer mehr geld
einzufordern
keine sorge es geht nicht um milliarden
sondern nur wenige millionen an drei
beispielen möchte ich jedoch
verdeutlichen wo haushaltsmitteln
zielgerichteter für unsere wertvollste
ressource wasser genutzt werden können
das thema meeresschutz wurde schon
angesprochen vor unseren küsten in der
nord und ostsee liegen geschätzt 1,6
millionen tonnen munition aus den
weltkriegen das entspricht 12.800 lkw
ladungen zum vergleich hintereinander
aufgereiht wäre das eine kolonne von
berlin nach hawaii
die schadstoffe der munition auch das
wurde schon angesprochen vergiften
zunehmend die meeresumwelt und bedrohen
damit zahlreiche arten und lebensräume
über belastete muscheln und fische
gelangen diese gifte auch in die
menschliche nahrungskette es besteht ein
fraktionsübergreifender konsens dass
hier gemeinsam mit den bundesländern
schon alles handeln dringend gefordert
ist bei kosten von geschätzt 100
millionen euro für den start der bergung
sind die im haushalt veranschlagten
4 millionen ein zögerlicher einstieg
hier hätten wir uns ein beherztes
vorgehen gewünscht
thema plastikmüll im meer ein großteil
der abfälle die im meer landen stammen
aus regionen mit schlecht entwickelten
abfall sammeln und verwertungs
strukturen in deutschland sitzen
unzählige innovative unternehmen die
wertvolles know-how beim sammeln und
verwerten von abfall haben mit dem
bestehenden programm zum export von
technologien gegen die vermüllung der
meere
die zeit läuft weiter die will nicht
angehalten fördert
den technologietransfer und leisten
einen wichtigen beitrag für die
nationalen umweltschutz dieses programm
funktioniert zeigt nicht zuletzt die
fast vollständige ausschöpfung der
bereitgestellten mittel umso weniger
verstehe ich dass die koalition bei
diesem wichtigen thema das gleichzeitig
den wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
statt den rotstift angesetzt hat und 8
millionen euro gestrichen werden sollen
das letzte thema das sie ansprechen
möchte ist im vergangenen jahr bei uns
in deutschland das schreckens sichtbar
geworden die flutkatastrophe im aartal
hat uns schmerzlich gezeigt wie wichtig
vorbeugende maßnahmen zur anpassung an
den klimawandel sind auch deshalb haben
wir als unionsfraktion kürzlich an den
antrag eingebracht der viele gute
vorschläge zur anpassung an den
klimawandel enthält wir wissen können
durch den klimawandel starkregen und
hochwasser deutlich zunehmen was du
immensen schäden führt es kostet sehr
viel geld und zeit die zerstörte
infrastruktur ist versorgungsleitungen
straßen brücken und gebäude wieder neu
zu errichten deshalb fordern wir mehr
geld in die fonds vorsorge zu stecken
und den klimagerechten hochwasserschutz
an den höheren stellenwert im haushalt
zu geben
[Applaus]
ich bin überzeugt dass jeder intelligent
eingesetzte euro zur vorsorge uns
künftig ein vielfaches an schäden
ersparen wird
und genau das wünsche ich mir von der
bundesregierung gegen sie dort geld aus
wo sie für jeden investierten euro das
meiste bewirken können wie beim wasser
empfiehlt sich auch beim geld ein
verantwortungsbewusster umgang mit
endlichen ressourcen
verschütten sie deshalb keinen tropfen
viel gelernt
die rede von alexander engelhard mit
einer kurzen lacht hier in dieser
debatte linda heitmann spricht als
nächstes sie ist mitglied von bündnis 90
die grünen
herr präsident meine damen und herren
wir diskutieren hier heute den haushalt
des ministeriums für umwelt naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz und auch wenn der
verbraucherinnen schutz hier an
allerletzter stelle in der aufzählung
steht so ist es mir uns hoffentlich auch
vielen anderen hier sehr wichtig dass er
trotzdem in unserer betrachtung und
diskussion nicht hinten runterfallen das
und das und das gute auch nicht wenn man
sich den haushalt ansieht wir haben im
koalitionsvertrag verankert dass wir die
verbraucher zentralen stärken wollen und
dass wir die arbeit der stiftung
warentest stärken wollen das bildet sich
in diesem ersten haushalt der ampel
koalition auch bereits ab und
und wir wollen verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher besser vor überschuldung
schützen
deshalb starten wir mit diesem haushalt
ein millionenschweres programm zur
stärkung überschuldeter verbraucherinnen
ich finde jetzt
jetzt dieser haushalt steht jetzt gilt
es ihn und das hinterlegte geld auch
wirklich mit leben zu füllen
unser maßstab als ampel ist dabei das
vorsorgeprinzip wir wollen die rechte
von konsumenten schützen und stärken und
wir wollen nachhaltigen und fairen
konsum ermöglichen aber
das glaubt uns muss dabei auch klar sein
den oder die durchschnitts verbraucherin
gibt es in deutschland nicht es gibt bei
uns ein unterschiedliches vorwissen bei
konsumentinnen es gibt eine
unterschiedliche gründlichkeit mit der
menschen die verträge prüfen die sie
abschließen es gibt auch
unterschiedliche vorstellungen von
nachhaltigkeit die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher in deutschland mitbringen
und sich auf diese unterschiedlichkeit
einzustellen und dabei allen
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern in
diesem land gerecht zu werden das ist
die herausforderung vor der wir als
ampel hier jetzt stehen
wenn ich dabei von unterschiedlichkeit
im verbraucherschutz rede dann müssen
wir uns zum beispiel auch das thema
mehrsprachigkeit angucken wir haben im
koalitionsvertrag
verankert dass wir mehrsprachige und
niedrigschwellige verbraucherbildung in
deutschland stärken wollen gerade auch
mit den haushaltsmitteln die wir hier
zur stärkung der verbraucher zentralen
eingestellt haben müssen wir dieses
vorhaben angehen die letzten monate gab
es schon gab es schon viele angebote
auch der verbraucherzentrale zb mit
russisch oder ukraine sprachigen apps
mit beratungsangeboten mit materialien
in vielen sprachen es ist wichtig dass
wir das auch wirklich verstetigen und in
die fläche bringen und dabei auch prüfen
wie wir erfolgreiche projekte wie zb
verbraucher stärken im quartier auch
nachhaltig sichern und verstetigen
können
nächster stichpunkt schuldnerin beratung
ich habe lange in der suchtkrankenhilfe
gearbeitet und ich weiß bei erkrankungen
wie spielsucht oder kaufsucht werden
ganze familien in den ruin getrieben
dabei ist es gerade beide der
schuldnerinnen beratung wichtig dass es
ja auch eine enge vernetzung mit
sozialen einrichtungen und hilfen vor
ort gibt und wir als politik müssen das
gewährleisten und müssen zusätzlich die
rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen dass
menschen mit den richtigen gesetzen auch
präventiv vor verschuldung wirklich
geschützt werden
ich habe kaum noch redezeit gern hätte
ich dir noch was zum thema green washing
gesagt auch dem wollen wir uns in den
nächsten jahren verstärkt widmen und
gerade bei diesem punkt ist es auch so
richtig und wichtig dass
verbraucherinnen schutz hier jetzt mit
umwelt und natur tötet zusammen gedacht
wird in einem ministerium deshalb wollen
wir gemeinsam wirken dass dieses thema
die nächsten jahre auch wirklich nicht
hinten runter fällt weder im haushalt
noch in der alltagspolitik vielen dank
die linda heitmann hat hier noch einmal
den zusammenschluss von umwelt und
verbraucherschutz begrüßt vorher war das
ja mit dem justizministerium
vereint nächster redner ist für die afg
fraktion jetzt jürgen braun herr
präsident meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren liebe kollegen
eine brutale zerstörung der landschaft
als sie mit windkrafträdern zu schmecken
und zu verriegeln hat zuvor keine phase
der industrialisierung verursacht es ist
die auslöschung aller dichter blicke der
deutschen literatur zitat ende so befand
botho strauß schon vor zwei jahrzehnten
der grüne windkraft waren führt
unweigerlich zu einer zerstörung über
jahrhunderte gewachsener
kulturlandschaften
aber die grünen von botho strauß auch
als ständer der landschaft seele
bezeichnet hatten ja noch nie etwas mit
umweltschutz am hut denn umweltschutz
ist zuallererst heimatschutz und heimat
fanden die grünen irgendwie steht zum
kotzen um einmal robert habeck etwas
frei zu zitieren warnungen auch aus der
bundeswehr durch den geplanten massiven
ausbau der windkraft kann unsere
luftsicherheit gestört werden doch der
grüne wahrnimmt auf nichts rücksicht
weder auf die sicherheit deutschlands
noch auf die interessen der anwohner
diese bundesregierung
diese bundesregierung einschließlich der
vermeintlich bürgerlichen fdp wollte
sogar direkt nach der nrw-wahl den
bundesländern das recht nehmen
mindestabstände zwischen wohngebieten
und wind industrieanlagen festzusetzen
diese viel gepriesene windindustrie
zerstört nicht nur unmengen an wäldern
und wiesen sie vernichtet vögel
fledermäuse und insekten die
windindustrie
die windindustrie soll nach dem willen
der bundesregierung auch direkt neben
deutschen dörfern in den himmel ragen
den grünen ging es immer darum
sozialistische utopien in grünem gewand
durchzuboxen wir erleben es derzeit dass
die unsinnigsten grünen projekte mit dem
ukraine krieg begründet werden aber
jetzt nötige energiepolitische
unabhängigkeit von russland erreichen
werden nicht durch wind industrieanlagen
sondern durch kernkraft und braunkohle
dass die verlängerung der atomlaufzeit
auch rechtssicher regelbar wäre hat
jetzt ein gutachten der ruhr universität
bochum gezeigt damit sind die einwände
des umweltministeriums hinfällig denn es
spricht auch juristisch nichts gegen
einen weiterbetrieb unserer
kernkraftwerke
vielen dank übrigens herr schäffler dass
sie das ausgesprochen haben was wir
schon lange gesagt gefordert haben als
afd afg wirkt wir müssen endlich weiter
unsere guten kernkraftwerke in
deutschland weiter betreiben
franz josef strauß hatte die deutschen
vor grün linken utopien gewarnt oder
steigen wir in das bunt geschmückte
narrenschiff utopia ein in dem dann ein
grüner und zwei rote die rolle des
faschings kommandanten übernehmen würden
heute schimmert die fdp mit auf dem
kunden narrenschiff utopia und cdu und
csu sind traurig dass sie nicht als
leichtmatrosen den grün-linken narren
assistieren dürfen
vielen dank herr kollege braun
nächster gegner ist der pflegekassen
träger spd-fraktion
lastenträger ist umweltpolitische
sprecher der sozialdemokraten im
deutschen bundestag
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen herr brauchen
sie sind ja ein großer zwischenrufe aber
nach der rede würde sich wünschen
schweigen sie einfach also das ist ja
wirklich wenn manchmal keinen moment
kopfschütteln ich bin froh dass wir
heute über den haushalt sprechen über
den haushalt des jedes jahr 20 22 und
ich bin stolz auf diesen haushalt sind
burg denn es ist ein haushaltsentwurf
der gut ist und es ist ein
haushaltsentwurf den schwierigen zeiten
aufgestellt werden muss schwierige
zeiten nicht nur weil in der nahen
ukraine ein angriffskrieg tobt nicht nur
weil wir noch nicht wissen was ob die
korona pandemie wirklich überwunden ist
sondern auch weil die zwei großen
menschheitsfragen der klimawandel und
die krise des artensterbens nicht
vorbeigegangen sind wir sind ja nicht
weg nur weil putin einen krieg vom zaun
gebrochen hat sind nur im bewusstsein
der öffentlichkeit ein stück nach hinten
gerückt und deswegen es ist eine gute
botschaft die dieses parlament aussendet
liebe menschen in deutschland ihr seid
bei dieser koalition in guten händen wir
sorgen für äußere sicherheit besorgen
für innere sicherheit und wir sorgen für
soziale sicherheit
über die äußere sicherheit wird viel
gesprochen in diesen tagen und wir
tragen den mit der einrichtung dieses
sondervermögens rechnung die innere
sicherheit hat viel mit der frage zu tun
wie lösen wir die energieabhängigkeit
von russland und während sie munter
weiter den fortbestand der atomkraft
fordern die ewiggestrigen dann kann ich
ihnen nur sagen wir arbeiten mit
hochdruck daran dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien entfesselt wird
just in diesem moment finden
berichterstatter gespräche statt damit
das ehrgeizige ziel erreicht werden kann
dass wir eine förderkulisse schaffen im
eeg die uns unabhängig macht von
energieimporten die uns mittelfristig
günstige energie beschert und die uns
vor allem eine energie szenario beschert
der nicht auf kosten der natur auf
kosten der gesundheit der menschen und
nicht riskant ist für den fortbestand
aller menschen und tiere in dieser auf
diesem planeten
wir werden ist zur sommerpause diese
gesetzespakete durch diesen bundestag
gebracht haben und ja es ist ein
hochspannender ein anspruchsvoller
zeitplan den wir uns vorgenommen haben
aber diese fortschritts koalition wird
in sechs monaten mehr geliefert haben
als er 16 jahre union in der
verantwortung geschafft haben und wir
werden damit fortsetzen in der zweiten
jahreshälfte
all das was unter dem thema planungs
beschleunigung und
verfahrensbeschleunigung zusammengefasst
wird das werden wir in der zweiten
jahreshälfte durch dieses parlament
bringen sodass wir 23 durchstarten
können und wirklich einen entfesselten
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien die sie
so hassen durchsetzen können
wir müssen die krisen zusammen denken es
bleibt uns gar nichts anderes übrig wir
werden gezwungen werden getrieben aber
es ist auch richtig die klimakrise
zusammen mit der biodiversitäts krise
zusammen zu denken denn das sind zwei
seiten der gleichen medaille
und wenn wir kluge lösungen finden dann
schaffen diese lösungen synergieeffekte
und tragen dazu bei dass wir diese
krisen mit diesen lösungen
wir heben können ein stichwort ist die
wiedervernässung von mooren diese moore
binden co2 sie erhöhen die biodiversität
sie halten das wasser in der fläche und
sind damit auch eine gute prävention
gegen zukünftige hochwassers
katastrophenalarm
inzwischen frage aus der fraktion nein
vielen dank die haben schon geredet uns
sozialdemokraten ist wichtig dass wir
die menschen mit mittleren und kleinen
einkommen dabei nicht aus dem blick
verlieren deswegen war es wichtig ein
energie entlastungs paket zu schnüren
deswegen ist es richtig dass der
sozialminister hubertus heil die idee
des sozialen klima geldes vorantreibt
wir arbeiten schnell und seriös wir
sorgen für äußere die innere und soziale
sicherheit finden
lastenträger fordert den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie zu entfesseln
allerdings will bundesministerin steffi
lemke mit einem bundes naturschutz vom
auch die arten schützen wenn diese durch
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
wenn es dabei zu einen artenschutz
verletzungen kommen kann
sie möchten die den ausbau der
windenergie
entfesseln
ihnen ist ja der thinktank
agora ein begriff denke ich mal
richtig teil der regierung mittlerweile
sagt mein kollege gerade und wir haben
einen ausbau von glaube ich ca knapp 70
gigawatt
windleistung und im moment also die das
letzte gibt es einen agora meter da kann
man jederzeit nachschauen wie viel
gerade produziert wird und der letzte
eintrag ist von 16 uhr und dort hat
quasi
on shore
1,79 gigawatt 17 9 gigawatt windstrom
nicht mal zwei prozent
ist schon klar dass wenn sie zum
beispiel auf 130 sie wollen wir die
kritik verstanden aber wir möchten sie
auf 100 30 gigawatt auch und wenn dann
quasi zwei prozent von 130 geliefert
wird also dann produziert wird dann sind
das dann eben auch sehr sehr wenig weil
sie nämlich 65 x 0 ist genauso viel wie
130 x 0 das heißt ihre energiewende ist
eine energiewende ins nichts sie kann
nicht funktionieren ohne speicher sie
haben keine speicher für große
kapazitäten und dann würde ich wollte
ich sie fragen wie sie das dann lösen
wollen wenn der wind wie jetzt im moment
gerade mal nicht wert
carsten hälse aus der afg fraktion war
das mit einer kurzintervention
frau und meine frau kollege hesselmann
sich alles was wir nicht verstehen nicht
alles was wir nicht verstehen ist
deshalb sinnlos
vielen dank herr präsident
mir geht es ganz ähnlich vielen dank für
die frage die ich leider nicht ganz
verstanden habe aber ich glaube sie
wollten darauf aus das wir speicher
brauchen für die energiewende ja da
haben sie recht vielen dank für die
flagge
mitmachen
werbeträger so habe ich das auch
verstanden also insofern bin ich froh
dass ich nicht der einzige bin der
nächste redner ist die kollegin judith
skudelny fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
kolleginnen und kollegen wir reden in
dieser woche über den ersten haushalt
den die ampelkoalition aufstellt und
innerhalb dieses haushalts sexuell
natürlich neue schwerpunkte weil wir
wollen ja die ampelkoalition als
fortschritt koalition gestalten und die
neuen schwerpunkte erkennen wir
insbesondere im bereich der umwelt und
verbraucherschutz politik indem wir
165 millionen euro
diesen haushalt aufstocken das ist eine
gute nachricht für die menschen in
deutschland
wir steigen in die beseitigung der
munitions altlasten ein wir etablieren
ein bisschen leben um die
kreislaufwirtschaft voranzubringen und
wir werden auch den beitrag zum
internationalen artenschutz auf der
cop15 in diesem jahr deutlich erhöhen da
arbeiten wir im parlament daran dass die
erhöhung innerhalb des innerhalb des
haushalts noch signifikanter wird weil
der internationale artenschutz steht im
moment aufgrund der ernährungskrise in
einem besonderen druck und da hat
deutschland eine besondere verantwortung
für
weitere vier milliarden euro kann das
umweltministerium aus dem klima- und
transformation sfo bewirtschaften und
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass das
ein sonderposten ist den wenn der
vergangenheit nicht hatten diese gelder
gehen nicht nur den klimaschutz die
maßnahmen dienen gleichzeit den erhalt
der artenvielfalt in deutschland der
landschaften und des naturschutzes ein
meilenstein auf dem weg zur
biodiversität in unserem land
umweltschutz zu erreichen habe nicht mit
geld allein unsere fortschritts
koalition hat sich auf die frage auf die
fahne geschrieben die vielen innovativen
ideen die die menschen die junge
startups die aber auch etablierte firmen
im bereich des umwelt und klimaschutzes
haben tatsächlich auch bei uns in
deutschland umzusetzen und dazu wissen
wir in den planungen schneller werden
wir sehen dass das neue lg
beschleunigungsgesetz und damit beweisen
wir es ja deutlich beschleunigt planung
umsetzen kann jetzt ist nicht jede
einzelne maßnahme die in diesen notfall
beschleunigung
enthalten ist dazu geeignet zum
regelfall zu werden was wir aber sehen
müssen ist dass wir klimaschutz wenn wir
ihnen in der zeit die wir benötigen und
die wir brauchen erreichen wollte dass
wir diesen klimaschutz nur dann
erreichen wenn wir schneller gehen auf
die planungs beschleunigung wird
insbesondere die fdp-fraktion wert legen
auch im bereich des verbraucherschutzes
müssen wir vorangehen die ampelkoalition
verbindet umwelt politik nicht nur mit
der wirtschaftspolitik wir haben auch
die verbraucher mit im blick und da gibt
es wirklich viel zu tun gerade in die
zeiten der inflation wir sehen dass der
tank rabatt den wir alle beschlossen
haben endlich bei den menschen ankommen
muss die steigenden energiepreise
befördern übrigens nicht erst seit der
ukraine krise probleme sondern die
billig stromanbieter haben schon im
januar gezeigt dass unredliches
verhalten in diesem bereich unterwegs
ist und dagegen müssen wir engagiert
vorgehen im rahmen der umsetzung der
erweiterten hersteller verantwortung
eine eu richtlinie müssen
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher in der
zukunft nicht mehr nur für manche
produkte die legale entsorgung bezahlen
sie müssen auch mit haften für die
illegale entsorgung mancher die fdp wird
darauf achten dass wir in allen punkten
konsequent aber auch mit augenmaß
vorgehen
die menschen haben schon heute mit den
folgen der inflation zu kämpfen
die fdp ist garant dass die aktuellen
belastungen in einer koalition der mitte
nicht dazu führt dass den menschen in
deutschland überlastet werden darauf
werden werden das augenmerk legen
der vorliegende haushalt ist der erste
von vier haushalten den wir als ampel
koalition gemeinsam aufstellen werden
rom wurde nicht an einem tag erbaut und
nicht alle ziele aus dem
koalitionsvertrag können schon im ersten
jahr umgesetzt werden aber dieser
haushalt ist ein schritt in die richtige
richtung und gemeinsam mit unseren
koalitionspartnern spd und grüne werden
wir unser projekt zum erfolg bringen der
schritt ist gemacht der stein ins wasser
geworfen er wird wellen schlagen und wir
werden gemeinsam erfolg haben
ein schritt in die richtige richtung
nennt judith skudelny diesen einzelplan
16 für umwelt und naturschutz auf sie
antworten wird nun christian hirte aus
der unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen frau ministerin
und meine damen und herren eine
haushaltsdebatte biete immer die
gelegenheit ein bisschen auch eine
generalaussprache vorzunehmen und
deswegen hat die ministerin bei der
ersten lesung aus meiner sicht zu recht
darauf hingewiesen dass krisen nicht
gegeneinander ausgespielt werden sollen
und ich zitiere sie wies darauf hin dass
es gelte die begrenzten finanziellen
ressourcen effizient zu nutzen für
klimaschutz und energie souveränität für
naturschutz und gesundheitsschutz für
kreislaufwirtschaft und weniger
abhängigkeit von knappen ressourcen
insoweit besteht ja wahrscheinlich noch
allgemeine einigkeit aber die
unterschiede beginnen dann welche
schlüsse man daraus zieht insbesondere
in der antwort auf den brutalen und
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff russlands
auf die ukraine und auch der energien
und lebensmittelversorgung die wir in
deutschland und weltweit haben und
deswegen will ich ausdrücklich sagen die
bundesregierung frau ministerin muss
noch beweisen wie sie mit ihr mit ihrer
angekündigten planungs beschleunigung
sächlich voran kommt und wie
insbesondere die große anzahl der
einwohner in den regionen dann
tatsächlich nachher reagieren etwa auf
den massiven windenergie ausbauen und
die regierung muss außerdem schauen wie
sie den angekündigten ausbau der
energie-infrastruktur mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit und aus der fdp zu
zitieren
voranbringen weil das auch so ein stück
weit ein lackmustest dafür ist wie wir
auch mit anderen großen
transformations- entscheidungen und
beschleunigung in unserem land
vorankommen wenn wir nämlich sehen
werden wie dann konkret wenn es dann
konkret wird vor ort die proteste von
frei dieses feature von der deutschen
umwelthilfe anderen naturschutzverbänden
und vielleicht auch von gelegentlichen
grünen ortsgruppen sehen werden ich
glaube das thema
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz hat gerade
darauf hingewiesen ist am ende auch ein
stück weit ein ganz entscheidender punkt
für die weitere für das für das große
ganze was was vor unserem land steht und
deswegen frau ministerin ist auch ihr
haus am ende nicht nur für die hier
angeschlagenen themen für den umwelt für
den naturschutz die nukleare sicherheit
und den verbraucherschutz zuständig
sondern eben auch für das große ganze 1
gewinnen eingebunden in die
verantwortung innerhalb der regierung
und da ist eine frage wie es gelingt
deutschland auch bei diesen von ihnen zu
verantwortenden themen im
internationalen standortwettbewerb so
hinzustellen dass wir weiterhin vorbild
sein können und schauen wir doch mal was
ernst & young uns gerade dieser tage ins
stammbuch schreibt nämlich dass wir in
deutschland mittlerweile
hinten anstehen im vergleich etwa zu
frankreich und großbritannien wo mehr
investitionen stattfinden weil sie der
attraktiveren standort sind vor allem
mit einfahren verwaltungsverfahren
schnelleren verwaltungsverfahren und vor
allem auch mit preiswerter energie
und deswegen zum thema akzeptanz ist es
mir wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass die
ministerin für
die nukleare sicherheit und den
verbraucherschutz eben schauen muss
definitiv wie die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung ist nicht nur beim ausbau
der erneuerbaren
nicht nur beim ausbau von energie
sondern zum beispiel auch beim
weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken
kollege schaeffler und auch andere
händler hingewiesen dass wir unter der
extremen energieknappheit unter der wir
stehen vielleicht ein stück weit auch
ernst nehmen sollten was ein übergroßer
teil unserer bevölkerung für richtig
hält nämlich unter
sicherheitsgesichtspunkten und unter
kostengesichtspunkten zu schauen wie man
die sicheren noch in betrieb
befindlichen kernkraftwerke weiter
vielleicht andere zeiten an und wenn
herr träger meint dass sein ewig
gestrige dann sollten sie mal schauen
wie viel prozent ihrer potenziellen
ehemaligen wähler sich als solche
ewiggestrige vielleicht betiteln lassen
wollen
und ein kleiner hinweis vielleicht an
die grünen wenn wir schon über das thema
potenzielle verlängerung von kernkraft
treten im wettstreit mit einer
eventuellen längeren und intensiveren
nutzung der kohle dann müssen sie sich
doch fragen auch im internationalen
maßstab ob sie ihrem eigenen anspruch
nämlich vernünftige klimaschutz politik
machen zu wollen gerecht werden wenn sie
eine klimaneutrale
technologie
ideologisch ablehnen ohne ernsthaft zu
prüfen möglichkeiten zu prüfen wie wir
es weiter nutzen können
und das gleiche gilt am ende auch für
unsere nationalen ressourcen etwa bei
biogas bei biokraftstoffen und bei
ähnlichem es ist ja leider der minister
özdemir nicht mehr da der sich im
europäischen kontext hinstellt und die
möglichkeiten
intensiver auch landwirtschaftliche
produktion voranzutreiben 4 prozent
stechen flächen gerade nicht
stillzulegen ausschlägt und das in einer
weltweiten hungerkrise ausgelöst durch
den krieg und die belagerung durch
russland ich halte das für ein stück
weit sogar für verantwortungslos und
deswegen sollten sie noch mal ernsthaft
darüber nachdenken auch für die nächste
saison ob sie da nicht auf einem holzweg
sind und im interesse unseres landes und
auch der weltweiten versorgung anderes
richtige und notwendig wäre letzte
anmerkung
der kollege engelhardt hat schon darauf
hingewiesen wir laufen auf eine massive
neuverschuldung hinten und tagesaktuell
stehen wir morgen vor der situation dass
der tank rabatt eingeführt wird das neue
euro ticket kommt mit all den
schwierigkeiten die damit zusammenhängen
schauen sie mal ob das wirklich
funktioniert ob wirklich am ende
diejenigen erreicht werden die in not
sind ob wir nicht morgen vielleicht doch
höhere preise haben weil märkte anders
funktionieren als sie sich das hinter
überwiegen klinken und ein kleines
bisschen gelben koalition überlegt haben
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
christian hirte hat hier unter anderem
kernenergie angesprochen seitdem ukraine
krieg ist die atomkraft ja doch wieder
thema ob sie verlängert werden soll auch
einige stimmen aus der fdp gibt es ja
die eine debatte dazu
fordern es dürfte also hier ab und an
noch thema werden tabea rößner spricht
jetzt für die grünen fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
samstags ist fast unbemerkt das gesetz
zur stärkung des verbraucherschutzes im
gewerbe und wettbewerbsrecht in kraft
getreten anbieter von online
marktplätzen müssen nun über rankings
und die vertrauenswürdigkeit von
kundenbewertungen informieren das ist
ein schritt zu mehr transparenz und dass
es auch gut aber
transparenz und information allein
reichen nicht es braucht klare regeln
für plattformen damit verbraucherinnen
auch selbstbestimmt und sicher im netz
sich bewegen können
die menschen kaufen zunehmend online ein
die korona pandemie hat das noch mal
befördert und damit nehmen auch
betrugsfälle zu die zahl der fehlschuss
hat sich gegenüber 2009 10
versechsfacht mit tricks und täuschungen
werden verbraucher innen um ihr geld
gebracht und ein drittel der deutschen
gibt an dass ihre persönlichen daten
schon mal missbräuchlich verwendet
wurden eine gerade veröffentlichte
studie der europäischen kommission zeigt
dass auch 97 prozent der beliebtesten
apps und websites dark patterns
angesetzt werden die verbraucher innen
verleiten gegen ihre eigenen interessen
zu handeln kein wunder dass sich die
meisten verbraucher innen in der
digitalen welt nicht sicher fühlen es
gibt also eine menge zu tun und das
müssen wir angeben
mitteln bietet services act soll ein
sicheres und vertrauensvolles online
umfeld geschaffen werden das stellt uns
in deutschland vor große
herausforderungen der mit dem neuen
nationalen it services koordinator
müssen wir eine aufsichtsbehörde
schaffen die nicht nur zwischen bund
ländern und eu ebene koordinieren soll
sondern das recht auf durchsetzen muss
und wie das so läuft hat jan böhmermann
am freitag im zdf deutlich gefragt da
steht uns eine gewaltige aufgabe bevor
und entscheidend ist nicht nur
effizienter aufsichtsstruktur mit
fachlicher expertise aufzubauen sie
müssen auch finanziell so ausgestattet
werden dass gegen illegale inhalte auf
wirksamen vorgegangen werden kann und
das wird in den nächsten
haushaltsberatungen eine baustelle sein
die menschen wollen nicht nur sicher
sondern auch nachhaltig konsumieren dass
es nicht leicht beim produkte immer
kürzere lebensdauer haben fest verbaute
akkus nicht austauschbaren und
ersatzteile nicht verfügbar sind so
produzieren wir jedes jahr
57 millionen tonnen elektroschrott
weltweit das muss man sich mal
vorstellen
das sind 350 kreuzfahrtschiffe des typs
queen mary 2 tendenz steigend und das
belastet den geldbeutel der verbraucher
innen aber vor allen dingen klima und
umwelt wir müssen daher zu einer echten
kreislaufwirtschaft kommen mit dem ziel
retten zu können
nachhaltigkeit nachhaltigkeit bei design
das muss der standard werden und mit
digitalen verfahren können wir
ressourcen viel effizienter einsetzen es
ist ein wichtiger schritt dass auf
eu-ebene die ökodesign trocken erweitert
und nun auch die textilbranche
adressiert wird und dass das
bundesministerium für umwelt und
arbeitsschutz das recycling label und
das aktionsprogramm reparieren statt
wegwerfen auf den weg bringt für uns ist
klar verbraucherschutz ist auch
umweltschutz und mit dem wechsel der
zuständigkeit ins umweltministerium
zeigen wir wir denken beides zusammen
digitalisierung die digitalisierung kann
treiber für nachhaltigkeitsstrategien
sein das kommt oft zu kurz
deshalb muss der digitale produkte auch
wirklich kommen und mit dem digitaldruck
können zb ersatzteile nachproduziert
werden ohne dass sie lange vorgehalten
werden müssen diese potenziale für einen
ressourcensparenden konsum müssen wir
heben mit dem aktuellen haushalt können
wir viele angekündigten maßnahmen
angehen es reicht aber nicht wenn
zuständigkeiten von dem ein ministerium
jetzt andere wandern wenn die stellen
nicht mitwandern das bleibt eine
baustelle für die nächsten beratungen
vielen dank
tabea rößner unter anderen zu einem
ressourcen sparenden konsum 19 millionen
euro will die bundesregierung für die
förderung von reparaturen einplanen mit
diesem etat damit eben die produkte
langlebiger werden und es weniger
abfälle gibt
thomas erhöhen jetzt für die afg
fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
nach der welt dümmsten energiepolitik
wie sie das wall street journal nannte
schicken wir uns nun an mit der welt
dümmsten umweltpolitik auf uns
aufmerksam zu machen typisch grün
verfällt die bundesregierung von einem
extrem ins andere
von der jahrzehntelangen verhinderung
wichtiger infrastrukturprojekte durch
grüne vorfeld institutionen um
juchtenkäfern und fledermäusen gerecht
zu werden bringt uns nun das sogenannte
oster paket der bundesregierung die
umweltpolitische 180 grad wende rodungen
für windkraft in wald und
landschaftsschutzgebieten möglichst ohne
jeden abstand zu wohnsiedlungen und das
auf zwei prozent unserer gesamtfläche
also landschaftszerstörung auf mehr als
7000 quadratkilometern planungs
beschleunigung der brechstange die
belange des umwelt- und artenschutzes
spielen dabei plötzlich eine völlig
untergeordnete rolle
alles für die grüne illusion man könne
die energieversorgung eines
industrielandes fast ausschließlich
durch wind und sonne sicherstellen nun
soll die zahl der windräder also
vervierfacht werden das aber wenn die
sonne nicht scheint und der wind nicht
weht viermal null immer noch null ist
ist grünen-politikern offenkundig nicht
zu vermitteln sollte unsere
energieversorgung im nächsten winter
wieder erwarten nicht komplett
zusammenbrechen wird es also daran
liegen dass wir atomstrom zb aus
frankreich in großen mengen einkaufen
werden dem frankreich welches gerade für
jedes akw welches wir abschalten zwei
neue aufbaut nachdem wir am beispiel
russischen gases gerade gelernt haben
wie problematisch abhängigkeiten von
anderen staaten sind machen wir diesen
fehler gleich noch einmal inzwischen
macht eine anekdote die runde nach
welcher ein französischer politiker
gefragt wird warum denn in frankreich
immer mehr atomkraftwerke entstehen die
antwort lautet damit die deutschen
unsere renten bezahlen meine damen und
herren das links grüne politik unsere
energiesicherheit gefährdet uns und
unseren wohlstand vernichtet wird gerade
den meisten klar die benzin strom gas
und lebensmittel nicht mehr zahlen
können dass am ende dieses ideologischen
amoklauf es auch zerstörte natur
landschaften stehen werden das hätten
sich viele allerdings nicht träumen
lassen eines lernen wir jedenfalls in
der heutigen zeit nämlich das grüne
umweltpolitik absolut beliebig ist dass
sie immer nur mittel zum zweck war um
die eigentlichen verdeckten ziele zu
erreichen und das schon seit ende der
siebziger als spätere grüne noch dem
kommunistischen bund angehörten was
stört uns unser grünes umwelt geschwätz
von gestern könnte man sagen vielen dank
[Applaus]
die kollegen der berliner seite hat
jetzt das wort für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen hier oben auf den
zuschauertribünen sitzen ganz viele
schülerinnen und schüler die uns heute
zu hören und wir behaupten hier im saal
ja immer wieder und zwar das tun alle
von uns wir machen generationengerechte
politik
wer sich einmal ernsthaft mit dem
atommüllendlager prozess
auseinandergesetzt hat der kann nicht
ernsthaft sagen
dass er generationengerechte politik
macht wer sich mal mit den kosten
auseinandergesetzt hat die atomenergie
produziert wer sich mal mit den risiken
auseinandergesetzt hat hier aus
atomenergie entstehen der kann hier
nicht stehen und sagen er macht politik
für die jungen menschen für die
nachfolgende generation
die kollegin collien
33 milliarden dollar an wirtschaftlicher
leistung stellt das ökosystem und
jährlich zur verfügung zwar ungefragt
und kostenlos für uns alle ich bin mir
sicher jeder finanzminister dieser welt
wäre froh so ein sondervermögen ohne
zinsen und verpflichtungen sein eigen
nennen zu dürfen die natur schafft
unsere lebensgrundlagen saubere luft
trinkwasser ertragreiche böden
lebensmittel sie gibt uns lebensraum und
freiraum sie trägt buchstäblich unsere
häuser und straßen sie stellt uns
baumaterial zur verfügung die mehrheit
der menschen hat ja nicht einfach ein
großes haus mit garten zur verfügung und
parkin bald ein see der bodensee die
sind systemrelevant das hat uns
spätestens die korona pandemie gezeigt
frau kollegin ist gelbe den wunsch nach
einer zwischenfrage aus der fdp-fraktion
ich verzichte sehr gerne auch wegen
auflegen der klimakrise sind wir auch
ökosystemleistungen angewiesen denn wir
brauchen gesunde böden wir brauchen
intakte moore großflächige bilder als
natürliche co2 speicher 33 milliarden
dollar das ist das von der natur
erschaffene sondervermögen auf das wir
wahrlich nicht verzichten können jetzt
sind wir ja gerade in
haushaltsberatungen und erinnern uns
zumindest in dieser woche das vermögen
das geld nicht einfach irgendwie im
haushalt drin ist sondern das muss man
sich erarbeiten dafür muss man
investieren und das genau tun wir in
diesem einzelplan 60 und das ist auch
dringend nötig der artenschwund
schreitet in einem dramatischen tempo
voran zwar nicht nur ein weit entfernten
regionen sondern auch hier bei uns vor
ort deshalb hat der schutz der
biologischen vielfalt einen besonderen
platz in diesem haushalt es gibt über
den bundes naturschutz fonds allein in
diesem jahr knapp 92 millionen euro und
deutlicher aufwuchs diese mittel sind
frei angelegt so dass je nach bedarf
verlagert werden könnten vor gehören zum
beispiel das bundesprogramm biologische
vielfalt
auch das hilfsprogramm ist darin
verankert dass die das dafür ausgegeben
wird um population schutzmaßnahmen beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien zu
finanzieren
aber
das muss man hier auch seine schutz der
biodiversität ist auch eine frage der
globalen gerechtigkeit mit unserem
kommission über schreibt mir nämlich
längst die landesgrenzen futter für
deutsche tierhaltung wird in brasilien
produziert unser obst und gemüse kommt
von überall auf der welt und es ist auch
eine frage der gesundheit nämlich da wo
wildnis zum acker wird wo lebensräume
der tiere zerstört werden können
neuartige krankheiten von tier auf
menschen überspringen ich spreche
natürlich von zoonosen eine davon
konnten wir einen wirklich in den
letzten zwei jahren nämlich mit der coop
1900 kann denn je wird es sehen und
deshalb beteiligen wir uns auch so aktiv
bei den verhandlungen zum
internationalen rahmenabkommen für die
biologische vielfalt wir wollen hier
verbindliche standards und konkrete
ziele definieren und es muss aber auch
klar sein dass auch in den kommenden
haushalten dafür finanzielle mittel
hinterlegt werden müssen sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir nutzen dieses
sondervermögen der der der natur indem
wir investieren vielen herzlichen dank
berliner seite war das für die spd
fraktions hier in der debatte zum
einzelplan
16 auf sie folgt steffen bilger erst der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der union zurückziehen
kolleginnen und kollegen und liebe frau
ministerin lemke sie haben bei der
ersten beratung ihres haushaltshilfen
hause vor gut zwei monaten gesagt so
sehr wir uns um das heute kümmern müssen
so sehr müssen wir dabei das morgen im
blick behalten sie haben das gesagt
angesichts des damals noch sehr jungen
russischen angriffskriegs auf die
ukraine und dessen folgen ich stimme
ihrer aussage voll und ganz zu damals
wie heute heute dauert der krieg aber
schon über ein vierteljahr und der
handlungsdruck wird tag zu tag größer
und zwar in jedem zuständigkeitsbereich
dieser bundesregierung auch die nieren
leider habe ich aber immer mehr den
eindruck dass sie diese selbst
formulierten anspruch nicht gerecht
werden so kam es denn durch den krieg zu
einer neuen prioritätensetzung im
bundesumweltministerium wo arbeiten sie
an neuen und auf diese große krise
angepassten antworten für das morgen
weiter so das sture abarbeiten des
koalitionsvertrags nibelungentreue zum
grünen parteiprogramm sind in meinen
augen alles nur kein krisenmodus
dabei müssen sie sich doch angesichts
der enormen herausforderung vor denen
unser land steht vor denen europa steht
auch die frage stellen wo zwingt uns
diese situation die dinge auch einmal
anders zu sehen prioritäten anders zu
setzen eigene position pragmatisch zu
revidieren und leider habe ich in diese
richtung von ihnen seit ende februar
nichts gehört heute in der debatte haben
wir von ihnen ja auch gar nichts gehört
dabei könnten sie die medial ab
gefeierte neue haus freundschaft mit
ihrem land wirtschaftskollegen letzte
mir nutzen und sich gemeinsam in brüssel
für einen pragmatischen weg bei der
umsetzung der neuen gemeinsamen
agrarpolitik einsetzen damit die
deutschen und europäischen landwirte
jetzt einspringen können wenn im
kriegsgebiet weniger getreide produziert
wird wenn andernorts auf der welt
hungersnöte drohen das tun sie aber
nicht
sie könnten die frage nach dem
vorübergehenden und ich sage bewusst
vorübergehenden weiterbetrieb der drei
noch am netz befindlichen kernkraftwerke
kollege hörte stand drauf eingegangen
offen prüfen lassen denn das was sie
bisher gemacht haben wir dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister zusammen war
keine offene prüfung sondern es war eine
zusammenstellung aller argumente die
dagegen sprechen und sie haben eine
verantwortung dass wir nicht jetzt kohle
noch länger einsetzen müssen statt
dieser klimaneutralen energie sie haben
auch eine verantwortung für die
versorgungssicherheit die sie wahrnehmen
müssen das tun sie hier aber nicht
und sie könnten angesichts der inflation
der steigenden preise gerade bei
produktions- und bei konsumgütern in
brüssel sich stark machen für ein
belastungsmoratorium denn da kommt er
gerade auch mehr auch aufgrund des
grünen deals uns sehr ganzen auflagen
die damit vorgesehen sind also
belastungsmoratorium wer jetzt das was
die bundesregierung in brüssel
einbringen muss das tun sie aber nicht
und sie könnten dafür sorgen dass
deutschland seine infrastruktur
schneller ertüchtigen kann und zwar in
allen bereichen damit wir die
kriegsfolgen
bewältigen damit mir klimaneutralität
erreichen können stattdessen
beschleunigung gibt es nur in
teilbereichen
koalitionsvertrag viele schöne worte der
letzten sitzungswoche haben wir über
planungs beschleunigungen diskutiert
aber deutlich wie groß die unterschiede
in den koalitionsfraktionen sinn als es
gleich zu befürchten dass sich viel zu
wenig tut beim thema plagens
beschleunigung dabei braucht deutschland
eine umfassende beschleunigung und
deutschland braucht seine
umweltministerin die sich dafür einsetzt
und das tun sie aber nicht
sie könnten sich in der bundesregierung
dafür stark machen dass deutschland
seine abhängigkeit von rohstoffimporten
reduziert indem die kreislaufwirtschaft
oberste priorität bekommt anstatt das
thema irgendwo im niemandsland zwischen
ihrem haus und im haus von herrn habe
verloren geht dort wo übrigens kein
einziges von sage und schreibe 200
zweifache verraten das thema überhaupt
im titel trägt das tun sie aber nicht
vielleicht auch weil sie daher keine so
besondere haus freundschaft verbindet
sie könnten auch frau ministerin obwohl
sie für den klimaschutz ja nicht mehr
zuständig sind die positive klimawirkung
von biokraftstoffen anerkennen so wie
das früher selbst getan haben oder sowie
dass ihre parteifreundin renate künast
getan hat die vor einigen jahren ja noch
gesprochen hat dass die bauern die
scheichs von morgen werden sie könnten
klarstellen dass der einsatz von anbau
biomasse in deutschland streng nach oben
gedeckelt ist übrigens strenger als von
der eu verlangt dass es gesetzlich
geregelten nachhaltigkeitsanforderungen
gibt dass abfall- und reststoffen klar
vorrang haben und das palmöl ohnehin ab
kommendem jahr nicht mehr angerechnet
wird weil wir das letztes jahr so
geschlossen haben und sie könnten das
tun anstatt die vermeintliche gunst der
stunde zu nutzen die für die erreichung
der klimaziele auf der straße zurzeit
wichtigste alternative zu diffamieren
und zu versuchen ihr den garaus zu
machen das tun sie aber nicht und sie
könnten schließlich als
verbraucherschutzministerin dafür sorgen
dass diese bundesregierung mehreinnahmen
die sie aufgrund der inflation erzielt
dafür einsetzt die inflations lasten zu
mildern anstatt sich in einzelmaßnahmen
zu verlieren sie könnten sich für ein
gesamtkonzept einsetzen dass die breite
unserer gesellschaft entlastet und zudem
auch eine anpassung des
einkommensteuertarifs an die
preisentwicklung gehört genauso wie eine
absenkung der stromsteuer und eine
energie pauschale von der auch studenten
rentner und junge familien in elternzeit
profitieren aber auch das tun sie nicht
also mein fazit frau ministerin lemke
das vertrauen in der politik steht und
fällt mit den zu trauern die menschen in
die fähigkeit auf herausforderungen und
krisen zu reagieren und es gehört
wirklich auch dazu in der lage zu sein
den eingeschlagenen kurs zu revidieren
da wo es macht sie selbst haben in ihrer
ersten haushaltsrede als verantwortliche
ministerin ja davor gewarnt im alten in
der hoffnung zu verharren so doch noch
eine weile über die runden zu kommen
damals war mir nicht klar dass diese
worte sich heute kann sich selbst
richten mein abhält deshalb korrigieren
sie ihre politik kommen sie endlich an
im krisenmodus
steffen bilger hat hier die
bundesministerin steffi lemke direkt
angesprochen sie wohnt der gesamten
debatte bei hertz ruhe ist allerdings
nicht auf der rednerliste mit einer
rheder vertreten
nadine hessel haus spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion verbraucherpolitische
sprecherin
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe zu
schauen ob lebensmittel strom oder
benzin alles wird teurer wir erleben
gerade die höchste inflation seit der
wiedervereinigung und die macht den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern in
deutschland schwer zu schaffen es ist
gut dass in diesen zeiten eine
sozialdemokratisch geführte koalition
das land regiert gemeinsam mit unseren
partnerinnen und partnern haben wir in
zwei paketen maßnahmen beschlossen die
die privaten haushalte um fast 24
milliarden euro entlasten
vom heizkostenzuschuss und der
energiepreis pauschale über den
kinderbonus bis zum 9 euro ticket all
das hilft den menschen in der aktuellen
situation
verbraucherpolitik ist aber noch viel
mehr als kurzfristig entlastungen zu
schaffen und gerade weil sie alle
menschen in nahezu allen bereichen
betrifft verdient sie auch mehr
aufmerksamkeit denn es geht darum die
position der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher systematisch zu stärken
dafür haben wir uns als koalition viel
vorgenommen und einiges spiegelt sich
bereits im haushalt wider den wir heute
beraten
meine damen und herren die eingangs
erwähnten preissteigerung interessen
haushalte unterschiedlich hart als
abgeordnete kann ich es jetzt
verschmerzen wenn ich mehr für strom
oder lebensmittel zahlen muss aber ich
bin auch alleinerziehende mutter und
kenne selbst lebenssituation in denen
man einfach irgendwie über die runden
kommen muss da wird beim wocheneinkauf
zweimal überlegt was in den
einkaufswagen korb bekommt und der
kinobesuch der fällt auch mal aus wenn
dann auch noch die nebenkostenabrechnung
eine horrornachricht gleicht ist die
belastungsgrenze schnell überschritten
vielen menschen droht so die
überschuldung und
überschuldung ist kein rein finanzielles
problem sie belastet menschen psychisch
und schließt sie von weiten teilen des
sozialen lebens aus die
schuldnerberatungen bieten hier die
notwendige hilfe an die nachfrage nach
beratungstermin steigt seit wochen und
sie wird weiter zunehmen
das angebot kann mit der nachfrage
jedoch kaum schritt halten zumal die
schultern beratung in deutschland
generell unterfinanziert ist im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir deshalb
vereinbart die schuldner- und
insolvenzberatung auszubauen und
finanziell zu unterstützen und das
setzen wir schon in diesem haushalt um
so fördern wir zb präventionsmaßnahmen
und die vernetzung von organisationen
die diese beratungen durchführen für
mich steht dabei fest dass wir das thema
verbraucher verschuldung in den
kommenden jahren noch intensiver in den
blick nehmen müssen ein weiteres
koalitionsvorhaben dass im haushalt
abgebildet wird ist das recht auf
reparatur die masse der in deutschland
in verkehr gebrachten elektrogeräte ist
zwischen 2013 und 2019 um 60 prozent
gewachsen und mit ihr auch der elektro
schrott
andererseits belegen umfragen dass die
meisten menschen ihr handy oder ihre
waschmaschine lieber reparieren lassen
würden als ein neues produkt zu kaufen
das wird ihnen jedoch von der industrie
oft unnötig schwer gemacht wenn geräte
zum beispiel so verbaut sind dass eine
reparatur praktisch unmöglich ist oder
wenn ersatzteile unverhältnismäßig teuer
sind mit dem aktionsprogramm reparieren
statt wegwerfen wird die bundesregierung
das angehen und verschiedene maßnahmen
auf den weg bringen die den reparatur
sektor stärken werden und damit auch die
konsumierenden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen produkten
länger zu nutzen und reparaturen zu
erleichtern schont ressourcen und damit
die umwelt das ist nachhaltige
verbraucherpolitik im besten sinne und
dafür steht diese koalition vielen dank
an all den kiesel haus war das für die
spd die
verbraucherschutzpolitische sprecherin
ist ja auch noch mal auf die
anstrengungen für mehr reparaturen
eingegangen auf sie folgt ebner er ist
der vorsitzende des umweltausschusses im
bundestag
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir befinden uns im größten artensterben
seit der menschheitsgeschichte und
allein wäre in dieser debatte werden
weitere zehn arten für immer von diesem
planeten verschwunden sein das ist
deshalb fatal weil damit die biologische
ökologischen netze zu dünn werden als
dass sie uns als menschheit auf dauer
tragen und ernähren können und ökonomen
bewerten das gerne monetär mit rund vier
billionen us dollar haben schutz ist
also eine auch ökonomische
überlebensfrage vor zwei wochen haben
deshalb über 1400 wissenschaftlerinnen
in ihrer berliner erklärung eine
trendumkehr zu gunsten von arten und
klimaschutz gefordert voller designs
kann ich hier nur sagen die ursachen
sind bekannt klimakrise ressourcenabbau
intensive landnutzung kollege pilger
pestizide flächenfraß vermüllung wir
müssen jetzt die lebensgrundlagen für
morgen sichern und mehrere krisen
bewältigen ohne sie gegeneinander
auszuspielen
und das war auch eine der grund
botschaften des weltwirtschaftsgipfels
in davos wir brauchen also gerade jetzt
mehr umweltschutz mehr naturschutz und
soliden artenschutz auch wenn mit dem
rückgang der arten des entstehungs
risiko von zoonosen und pandemien steigt
artenschutz ist deshalb auch
gesundheitsvorsorge
biodiversität ist die grundlage von
widerstandsfähigen ökosystemen ohne die
wir nicht überleben können ohne
bestäuber gesundes bodenleben sind gute
ernten unmöglich auch deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir gerade jetzt gerade
jetzt landwirtschaft naturverträglich
betreiben sodass sie mit
funktionierenden ökosystemen die erträge
von morgen und übermorgen
sichert und wir müssen auch wunder von
flächen konkurrenzen der anbau von
energiepflanzen für agrosprit lässt
andere hungern und der anbau von
futtergetreide macht die viele tiere es
hat aber viel zu wenig menschen kollege
bürger
und zum ewigen gebet zum ewigen gb zur
atomkraft ist er jetzt von mehreren
angesprochen worden kollege bilder und
andere der hirte
53 prozent des urans kommen aus russland
kasachstan usbekistan viel spaß bei raus
aus der abhängigkeit wir haben
keine einzige atomanlage dieser welt ist
für kriegssituationen ausgelegt und da
reden sie vom weiterbetrieb der
atomkraft stichwort endlager ich habe
noch keinen gefunden ich habe noch
keinen gefunden der laut hier schreit
wenn es darum geht wo soll es denn hin
im bundeshaushalt geben wir jedes jahr
eine milliarde aus für die soldo des
atommülls und sie von der verlängerung
der atomkraft da gäbe es eine zwischen
fahrer aus der haptik danke nein danke
so eine zwischenfrage aus der
unionsfraktion möchten sie die zu lassen
die ja gerne bildschirm
vielen dank dass sie die zwischenfrage
zu lassen sie haben das thema uran
angesprochen die zahlen per sie waren
natürlich korrekt aber es ist ja auch so
dass wir seit vielen vielen jahren ein
weltweites überangebot sogar sehen an
uran auf den märkten brennelemente ist
ein anderes thema aber urans lieber
angebot und 25 prozent des urans werden
in australien und kanada hergestellt
also ein knappes problem gibt es an der
stelle zumindest nicht würden sie da
zustimmen
wer würde ich nicht zustimmen allein
wenden wenn sie die zahl 25 nennen dann
sind 25% einfach 75 prozent weniger als
100 so und daraus sehen wir schon dass
in knapp heitz problem erkennen kann
entstehen kann so
klima arten und ernährungskrise müssen
an der stelle zusammen gelöst werden die
artendaten nicht mit dem aussterben bis
wir andere probleme gelöst haben und
deshalb ist es auch so wichtig dass die
internationale artenschutzkonferenz in
diesem jahr stattfindet und nicht noch
einmal geschoben wird und deshalb ist es
auch wichtig dass wir für den
internationalen artenschutz auch
zusätzlich geld in diesem haushalt
bereitstellen und
die
globale finanzierungslücke beim
internationalen artenschutz
dies so derart groß dass das was wir
dieses jahr machen nicht reicht wir
müssen weiter dran an geld wird es nicht
mangeln 67 milliarden
geschäfte umweltschädliche subventionen
könnten wir einsparen da ist viel luft
nach oben das haben auch die
wissenschaftler in der berliner
erklärung gefordert es geht auch ohne
jede steuererhöhungen also wir haben
noch möglichkeiten gut was für den
umwelt- natur- und artenschutz zu tun
und es auch gemeinsam zu denken
dankeschön
harald ebner war das für bündnis 90/die
grünen und es gab ein bisschen aufruhr
in der fdp fraktion
und jetzt gibt es auch eine
kurzintervention von peter boon aus der
art die fraktion
vielen vielen dank frau präsidentin dass
ihr die frage zu lassen ich will sie
auch nicht überfordern das ist etwas
erstes semester volkswirtschaft sie
haben hier nämlich die drohgebärde an
die wand gemalt von wegen wir würden uns
in abhängigkeit begeben gerade von
russland kasachstan und der kult
wer bitteschön es sitzt am längeren
hebel in einer freien marktwirtschaft
derjenige der etwas verkauft oder der
etwas kauft ja das haben sie schon mal
darüber nachgedacht und der kollege von
der cdu hat das schon sehr treffend
gesagt haben hirn ein überangebot auf
dem markt und selbst bei anderen
fossilen rohstoffen wie auch gas oder öl
das worauf sie an gespielt haben dass
wir uns in die abhängigkeit von russland
begeben also bitte sehr russen haben
immer zuverlässig verzögern zu zeiten
des kalten krieges haben sie verkauft
weil sie auf unser geld angewiesen sind
diesen die verkäufer die brauchen das
geld das heißt wenn jemand etwas ab
stellt dann sind wir das wieder wir
sagen wir stellen die käufe ab weil wir
am längeren hebel sitzen also bitte
warum zeichnen sie hier so eine
drohgebärde die überhaupt nicht
entspricht
herr ebner hat macht den eindruck als ob
beantworten möchte bitteschön
die verlässlichkeit von russland als
lieferant von gas und anderen rohstoffen
haben wir in den letzten tagen und
wochen sehr gut beobachten können die
ist gleich null an der stelle deshalb
ist es notwendig dass wir da aus
jeglichen abhängigkeiten rauskommen
deshalb diversifizieren wir auch die
abhängigkeiten vasile energielieferungen
angeht das ist gut und das ist richtig
so und ich sage ihnen eines wer am
allerwenigsten uns den hahn zudrehen
kann ist die sonne und ist der wind das
wollen sie ja nicht aber das ist der
richtige weg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich schlage vor dass wir jetzt die
kollegin tochter franziska kerzen
anhören für die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen leider
sind schon viele von den zuschauern
hinweg ich freue mich dass sie noch da
geblieben sind
wenn wir uns den haushalt anschauen
erkennt man recht schnell dass wir in
einer krisensituation stecken das
sondervermögen bundeswehr die
energiepreis pauschale hohe pandemie
ausgaben ganz klar wir befinden uns in
einer außergewöhnlichen situation
das sind aber kurzfristige krisen die
manchmal den blick auf die langfristigen
probleme etwas versperren klimawandel
und biodiesel biodiesel sie teetz krisen
dabei ist es fünf vor zwölf ein drittel
aller tier pflanzen und pilzarten in
deutschland sind gefährdet in manchen
regionen sind wir schon gehört haben
mehr als zwei drittel des insekten
bestandes schon verloren gegangen
deshalb unterstütze ich alles was meine
vorredner aus der koalition aus der
koalition bisher gesagt haben die knapp
92 millionen euro für den bundes
naturschutz form sind genauso richtig
weil die mittel für die verschiedenen
programme vereint und flexibel
gehandhabt werden können die mittel zur
internationalen zusammenarbeit
insbesondere für die un
biodiversitätskonferenz in kunming sind
genau aus dieser logik auch mehr
aufgestockt worden wir brauchen einen
paris moment für die biodiversität
die mittel helfe ich natürlich im
klimaschutz und energie und klimafonds
zeigen dass wir den artenschutz ernst
nehmen und mit dem klimaschutz gemeinsam
denken denn was einmal an biodiversität
verloren gegangen ist kommt nicht wieder
ich unterstütze deshalb ausdrücklich
dass dem umwelt haushalt die forschung
zu ki und digitalen lösungen für den
umweltschutz gestärkt werden
investitionen zur verminderung von
umweltbelastungen
verdoppeln wir nahezu von 25 auf 42
millionen euro
da ich neben dem umweltausschuss auch im
landwirtschaftsausschuss tätig bin hat
mich besonders gefreut dass sich die g7
agrarminister diesem monat zum [ __ ]
heldts ansatz bekannten der die grund
gesundheit der umwelt der menschen und
der tiere zusammenhängt betrachtet hier
steht die minimierung und ein genuss von
susan als auch von
antibiotikaresistenzen auch eine gefahr
die uns echt droht in landwirtschaft und
ernährung system im fokus für mich als
agrar und umwelt politikerinnen
verbinden die drei themen erneuerbare
energien ernährung und biodiversität 1
punkt ganz klar es sind flächen
konkurrenten wenn wir 30 prozent
schutzgebiete sichern wollen haben wir
weniger fläche für produktion und
lebensmittel von lebensmittel und
energie um diese flächen problematik
anzugehen müssen wir jetzt
gesamtgesellschaftlich denken durch
frühe beteiligung können den druck auf
die flächen mehr reduzieren und auch
mehr akzeptanz schaffen
unser alter freund als partner hat so
mutige politik lange blockiert das ist
bei uns anders
unsere koalition packt es an und findet
auch starke kompromisse zum beispiel
rosa paket das eckpunktepapier zum
ausbau der windkraft an land stellt ein
kompromiss dar für einen seit jahren
bestehendes problem noch sind nicht alle
fragen im detail geklärt wie soll
gewährleistet werden dass die
populationen gefährdete arten geschützt
werden oder erhalten bleiben wie können
wir strukturen und kapazitäten vor ort
stärken da müssen wir in den nächsten
wochen noch stärker diskutieren damit
die heute vorgestellten mitteln auch
gezielt abfließen wenn wir alle heute
vorgestellten programme jetzt richtig
umsetzen haben wir einen haushalt der
nicht nur kurzfristige lösungen
verspricht sondern auch langfristige
lösungen schafft dank
franziska kersten war das für die spd
fraktion und damit kamen wir zum letzten
redner in dieser debatte zum einzelplan
16 es ist jakob blankenburg für die spd
er ist sprecher für nachhaltige
entwicklung seiner partei seiner
fraktion frau präsidentin meine damen
und herren ich möchte diese rede beginn
mit zahlen die den fans fans deutscher
in die musik bestens bekannt sein
dürften ich zitiere nur weil man sich so
daran gewöhnt hat ist es nicht normal
nur weil man es nicht besser kennt ist
es nicht noch lange nicht egal diese
zahlen stammen von der hamburger band
kettcar kettcar werden am freitag bei
der 33 kulturellen wieder spannend
widerstands papieren gorleben auftreten
direkt vor dem dortigen atomaren
zwischenlager mitten im wendland dem
inbegriff der anti-atom-bewegung woran
wir uns schon längst gewöhnt haben etwa
eine milliarde euro jährlich schließen
die zwischen und endlagerung
radioaktiver abfälle
wir haben es heute schon gehört das ist
knapp die hälfte des diesjährigen etats
des bundesumweltministeriums diese summe
wird jahr für jahr aufgebraucht um
radioaktive abfälle sicher zu lagern
und den bestmöglichen standort für
radioaktive für eine art für ein
endlager für radioaktive abfälle zu
finden wir haben uns daran gewöhnt aber
es ist nicht normal und es kann es auch
nicht egal sein
diese zahlen belegen und auch das wurde
in dieser debatte schon gesagt dass die
nutzung der atomenergie alles andere als
kostengünstig ist die nutzung dieser
energieform hat enorme folgekosten und
diese sind nicht nur in euro zugemessen
künftige generationen werden bis zu eine
million jahre mit den
hinterlassenschaften unserer
energieerzeugung umgehen müssen jeder
tag an dem teil neuer hoch radioaktiver
müll aus deutschen atomkraftwerken
hinzukommt ist wichtig
und deshalb liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen halten wir daran fest dass die
letzten drei noch aktiven atomkraftwerke
in deutschland ende dieses jahres vom
netz gehen da reicht ein blick in den
prüfer merkt den bsv und bmw
cabrios gefertigt haben und dort ist
ganz klar darin geregelt selbst wenn sie
es wollten ist wäre unwirtschaftlich ist
macht keinen sinn und an die kolleginnen
und kollegen aus der fdp würde ich den
würde ich einen blick in den
koalitionsvertrag empfehlen seite 47
falls das hilft ihr widerstand
generationen von menschen haben für
diesen ausstieg aus der atomenergie
gekämpft in gorleben und in vielen
anderen ecken deutschlands und ihr
widerstand hat sich gelohnt das motto am
freitag heißt zu recht gorleben raus akw
s aus
wie gefährlich atomkraftwerke und
atommüll sind hat uns die dramatische
situation in den ukrainischen
kraftwerken in folge der russischen
angriffe einmal mehr verdeutlicht wir
müssen unter hochdruck daran arbeiten
die hochradioaktiven abfälle aus der
jahrzehntelangen nutzung der atomenergie
schnellstmöglich tiefen geologisch
einzulagern der deutsche bundestag hat
für die suche nach dem bestmöglichen
standort für ein solches endlager und
zwar im jahr 2017 ein verfahren
beschlossen übrigens auch mit den
stimmen der unionsfraktion und dieses
verfahren soll partizipativ
wissenschaftsbasierte transparent selbst
hinterfragen und lernen sein das mag
erstmal sperrig klingen aber genau das
ist der richtige weg und eine solche
standortsuche geht nur mit den menschen
und nicht gegen sie das haben wir unter
anderem aus gorleben gelernt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen deshalb
ist die bürgerinnenbeteiligung in allen
phasen der standortsuche einer der
zentralen aspekte und die mittel aus dem
in dieser woche zu beschließenden
bundeshaushalt sind hier gut angelegt
der umgang mit den hinterlassenschaften
unserer energieerzeugung geht uns alle
an und ganz besonders die junge
generation
sie wird die inbetriebnahme des
endlagers für hochradioaktive abfälle
miterleben für sie wird dieses endlager
irgendwann normal sein und geben wir uns
mühe sie auf dem weg dahin bestmöglich
mitzunehmen mit dem einzelplan 16 legen
wir die grundlage dafür vielen dank
jakob blankenburg war dass hier der
letzte redner in dieser debatte zum etat
des
bundesumweltministeriums